president biden facing new trouble in
the new year the far left is reportedly
sizing up a challenger to primary biden
if he seeks a second term a progressive
strategist explaining why quote
he's deeply unpopular he's old as bleep
must've been talking to dana he's been
largely ineffective and i think he'll
probably get demolished in the midterms
even msnbc a local tv station thinks
biden has become a liability for the
democrats it is difficult when you have
the biden administration struggling in
so many parts of the country whether the
two things that you think he needs to
make sure he has accomplished by june of
2022 in order to raise his number so
that he is not sort of a a albatross on
the neck of where probably of democrats
are going to be running this fall
all right harold i see right through you
i know what you are up to you democrats
you what you're trying to do is you're
trying to create this fog of progressive
challengers to help joe
look moderate and look sane and america
fell for that before but we're not going
to fall for it again i see right through
you harold right through you don't look
away
well you might but you might but i'd put
in a little historical perspective when
president george h.w bush got a
challenger to the right and pat buchanan
and he lost
uh jimmy carter before that in in teddy
kennedy he lost
um i think when you when you when you
think about the kind of challenges that
a president uh faces um you don't want
them from in your party it certainly
spells challenges for you in your
election year i don't know what will
happen in 2024 but i know this crime
covets supply chains and inflation uh in
the border if they just focused on two
or three of those they could find
themselves in a better spot i would urge
progressives who are out fominating
these kinds of things i don't know that
pollster or that person that you quoted
there in the piece but if you're serious
about helping joe biden in the country
pass something
take victories that are in front of you
help every american i thought phil
levine had the former mayor down in
miami beach had a great piece in the new
york post today we outlined things that
democrats should be for and if you can't
find phil levine's piece and you're
having difficulty understanding what it
means to get a win look to the new mayor
of new york
look to what he's about talking about
covet and crime and moving the city
forward the democratic electorate in new
york elected a mayor who frankly is
probably to the right of joe biden on
things that's where the democratic party
is those who think that we are
progressives or even progressives who
believe we're going to win with this
kind of messaging that they're
presenting i think they're dead wrong
all right so harold essentially you're
saying he will be impeached
[Laughter]
you know uh judge let's get down to the
most important question here old as
bleep what do you think the bleep was
stop it dirt d-i-r-t
dirt old as dirt no no i don't like by
the way i don't really like that you
were shading dana with that one
well you know what it is technically
dirt true it's a form of compost yeah
humans make their own dirt but i just i
just want to say one thing here's the
thing about and harold that you made so
much sense there
all it is is about doing something for
the american people we're fed up with
people who sit there and do nothing but
complain and watch the lunacy that is
going on around us we're fed up with it
we work hard we pay our taxes we do
everything we're supposed to do and we
expect and they expect that we're going
to say yeah we want joe in there yeah
that administration's doing great one
thing you left out harold was
afghanistan that is the most outrageous
thing that happened in the whole year as
far as i'm concerned in terms of oh
leave no american behind but we left a
few hundred i mean whatever 90
um you know this is about them working
for the american people and if they
can't do it get out and get them out
there you go jesse uh what are your
thoughts on this in between feeding
liquid viagra to your pets
greg the waters apology tour has to
continue i have gotten so many text
messages from my mom
i haven't heard this much from my mom
since january 6th
mom i was being irreverent when i was
telling the story about the children's
style at all it did not happen that way
i hope that was clear
with that said
listen if i was a member of the squad i
would want federalizing elections
socialized medicine tax hikes gun
grabbing the green nude deal joe hasn't
given me that because he's been blocked
by the courts the constitution and joe
manchin but he's met him halfway he's
given them open borders and reckless
spending they're still not happy they
want a hundred percent of their agenda
they want total control over your life
people in the audience have probably
dated other people like that and we know
how painful that can be but do i feel
sorry for joe biden no i work at fox i
want to see disarray on the left it's
good for america it's good for our
ratings i want to see this guy primaried
by rich liberals crazy liberals so much
so that they can hit the threshold to
pop the
debate so he has to argue with
communists about whether they're gonna
fund
solar paneled slavery reparations which
which squad member would you like to see
run against him oh aoc comes to mind
you know uh i would i would actually
like prefer ill on omar because then we
could see her first brother
yo dana
i don't i'm not a big fan of ageism um
uh saying that joe is as old as bleep
what are your thoughts on that well i
think that
everybody reads differently in terms of
how they age right so you know people
that are his same age 78 who seem a lot
younger
or a lot older
but they have to dance with the one that
brought them but the good news for
republicans is that no leader in the
democratic party is listening to harold
yeah
because no offense what did you have
happened today
senator schumer comes out and he says
i'm putting the stake down and i'm
saying that by martin luther king day we
have to have this voting rights bill
passed or else we have to change up the
filibuster rules knowing knowing that
they don't have the votes for that they
just like they didn't have the votes for
buildback better so they constantly set
themselves up to step on their own rake
if they listen to harold they might have
a better chance there you go
all right don't step on any rakes
coming up an nfl star having a meltdown
on the field what set the whole thing
off next hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else